and
cornetse event was a big contributor
last year in the regular season when
they had those injuries and yopics was
playing considerable minutes early this
season they both missed a long period of
time
with with injuries and now getting at
least a taste of some playoff action
jams of rewind hazard
it's his last year in the NBA he's
already said this will be his final
season came here undrafted player after
a year
University of Florida where's Chicago
with a 140 Garnett gets it away from
here to Ben
and it's Pritchard to cornette to
mostawa and the mccrelinghausen
[Music]
and a foul
[Applause]
now
this place would go absolutely bananas
and started taking off his warm-up
you're talking about a guy who is the
heart and soul of this Miami Heat team
he's turning the season you mentioned
this Kevin I want to be his last and
when the heat were going through their
Growing Pains this season coach there
was a lot of games
being shown of Haslam the frustration on
his face yelling at his teammates
getting going when Al Horford was going
in the coach's seat trying to motivate
these guys
but in the same breath of Dwyane Wade
Alonzo Mourning he's cut from the same
clock